it's been over three years since
Breaking Bad ended yeah almost three and
a half three and a half years yeah and
and people obviously that shows so
beloved there are still rumors that it's
coming back do you hear this a lot all
the time people post stuff here's a fake
ad online they're on up and it had a lot
of people believing it had me almost
believed it had you almost believe there
I'm like what is happening yeah what are
they not telling me don't you that could
have meant something about your life how
do you for a second think that there
could be a Breaking Bad Rooney that you
weren't told about just you know wishful
thinking yeah yeah that's really cool
obviously you can't go anywhere in the
world without people yelling out [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah all day every day wherever
I'm at yeah and what's weird is that
apparently that was a word that you were
allowed to say on the show all the time
because the censors approved it the
network approved it yeah it's still
funny we got a Vince Gilligan our
creator of Breaking Bad sent out this
note that he got he just laughed at it
because we were allowed to say as many
[ __ ] as you wanted we had six shits
per year right and then one year like
that once
turns out it was too much cheese where's
that chopped up with a rim shot when you
need it
we're on we're allowed to have six six
shits and then also one one yeah but
only one yeah yeah now I know that
[Applause]
two-second child comes along and you
know what it is
you only have one birthday a year that
is so strange because that's throughout
the years I've worked in television you
get such strange notes years ago and I
worked on Star Night Live they would
always say I'd write a sketch and say oh
you can't say that but then they would
okay something that was much worse yeah
it was insane major Lawrence yeah I
don't know but you're allowed to do it
and then because you said [ __ ] so often
because you were allowed to that became
probably the coolest catchphrase anybody
could have don't you think yeah yeah
what if your line yeah what if your line
had been like I like pasta you know your
character suddenly is one third is cool
yeah it's I don't know if that would
really go over all that well no I mean I
do like pasta I know it made the right
choice
you